est ce que vous avez reçu vos
invitations tous les huit ans non il y
en a qui les ont reçus regardez bien
qu'ils ont reçu des invitations regardez
regardez ce bureau mais pas chic
j'ai lu à haute voix confiance aux gars
gardent voir sa tombe pas là qu'on
assiste à face à moi fortement attaché
toujours comme tous les to you tube en
caméra cachée je le dois à tous on va se
voir que longtemps des journées ça va
l'année prochaine que son mythe
l'habitude le super bon gars qui sait
qu'apple pas alors je suis avec motards
sont en train de négocier fond je lui
demande tout de suite tu as une
invitation pour les 80 ump
une invitation pour les 81 pc c'est la
teinte franchit pas la barre a reçu
d'invitation pour les 8 ans
il a reçu c'est bon parce limitation
pour autant ces huit attend justement
tard suis à la cotation pour les 80 est
mort c'est moi merci
elle était au budget on était au but de
la série et voilà c'est lui resta le
directeur général de production qui vous
a fait croire qu'il était en travaux il
viendra bureau un peu bizarre et mise en
scène derrière ça on va venir ça sera
pour une interview pour sert il
et puis on attendait tous et lionel syne
débarquer détient d'ailleurs bien viens
viens juste avant j'ai en moi parler
d'année prochaine de mon bureau et là on
se fait avoir